in my experience if you can avoid some
or all of these mistakes you will be a
more successful language learner number
one is expecting that you can learn
facts that we're going to learn the
language quickly and this is usually
followed by the conviction that you
can't learn at all so the number of
people who are expecting to learn the
language in a few weeks and there are
systems and people who promise you know
rapid success and of course they don't
achieve the rapid success and then
people think well I just don't have a
talent for language learning part of
that too is because of the way languages
are taught at school where many of the
Learners are motivated where there's an
emphasis on
you know passing tests and so people
become convinced that the cap learned
but one of the reasons for people
thinking they can't learn is because
they have unrealistic expectations